none of us are unitary personalities
it's the nature of the mind to have lots
of different what I call parts and that
those parts are all valuable an example
would be something happens in my life it
triggers this critic who's brutal and
makes me feel horrible and that brings
up a part that feels young and empty and
alone and worthless and that feeling is
so distressing that then this binge
comes in to get me away from it the
bench triggers the critic again who's
calling me a pig on top of the other
names these aren't just Little Voices or
thought patterns or emotions those are
the manifestations of these parts if I
were to have you focus on one of them
you'd find out that it's a full range
personality that really has a lot to
tell you but besides the little thought
it's giving you and that it's stuck in
an extreme role because of something
that happened in your childhood maybe
and through trial and error over time we
found out how to help all these parts
change and become who they're designed
to be